foreign
Abrams tank is one of the most powerful
ground weapons in the U.S Arsenal
equipped with a 1500 horsepower turbine
engine and a top speed of more than 40
miles per hour it comes with a 120
millimeter cannon three machine guns and
armor that can withstand frontal hits
from enemy tanks with minimal damage and
these tanks could help Ukrainian forces
take back Russian occupied territories
but Pentagon officials have expressed
concerns that these tanks could pose
major logistical issues for Ukraine
Abrams requires a lot of support and if
the ukrainians don't have everything
that it takes to operate the Abrams they
might end up being more of a detriment
than they are a help if ukrainians want
to take full advantage of the M1 Abrams
Tanks they'll have to solve several
major logistical challenges
so this binder right here this contains
all the the information and coordinating
details to operate a battalion of Abrams
tanks for four days in the field Dan
griesher is a Marine Corps veteran who
operated Abrams tanks for almost a
decade all Western tanks are a lot more
complex than the old Soviet tanks
there's a lot of upgraded Electronics
they're much more intricately designed
Ukraine already has a lot of skilled
tank operators who have experience
working on older soviet-era tanks like
t-72s you got to remember they've been
fighting the Russians since 2014. so
they are not going to be starting from
scratch learning how to drive a tank
here they will have to learn how to use
the Abrams Tanks they'll have to learn
how to use the you know the targeting
system the Abrams is a four-person tank
the Soviet tanks have three people in
them so they'll have to learn details
but if you know how to drive a tank you
know how to drive a tank so one way to
think about this would be you go from a
10 year old Toyota to a a new Tesla you
know how to drive you just have to learn
how to do it on this new vehicle these
new Abrams Tanks boast impressive
technology the tech enables troops to
fire at night from longer ranges than
Russian tanks navigate through Waters up
to four feet deep and shoot rounds with
a range of two and a half miles but the
more complicated the technology the more
likely it is to break and depending on
what needs to be repaired the parts may
need to be sent all the way back to
manufacturing plants in the U.S then
after they're repaired they'll need to
be sent back to Ukraine a lot of the
individual components inside the tank
were designed not necessarily to be
repaired in the field but to be replaced
in the field it could be days or
possibly even weeks for them to get a
replacement component and if a tank has
to wait on a replacement part if the
tank doesn't get everything that it
needs in terms of of spare parts of fuel
of even lubricants and and hydraulic
fluid you only have to lose one or two
of those things to render a tank
ineffective and it becomes a little more
than a giant 72-ton paperweight on the
battlefield and one of the most
logistically difficult parts for
maintaining an M1 Abrams tank is fueling
it the reluctance
within the Pentagon to sending the
Abrams Tanks had a lot to do with how
difficult it is to keep them in the
fight Abrams Tanks use a lot of gas
because they're very large heavy
Vehicles so it takes a great deal of
energy to be able to even get that thing
to start moving in order to avoid the
risk of running out of fuel Abram's
tanks typically travel with fuel trucks
the tanks can store about 500 gallons of
fuel and can go about 275 miles on a
single Phillip and while it takes a lot
of gas to start and run in Abrams tank
it also consumes a huge amount of fuel
even when it's idle just the the
capacity is going to be the big
challenge just making sure that they
have enough fuel to power these tanks
that might be a challenge for them tanks
are only one part of the the overall
equation the tanks require a lot of
support so they require refueler
Vehicles they require maintenance
Vehicles they require ammunition trucks
you know to support them and if you take
those out if you're really able to
disrupt that supply chain then the tanks
are irrelevant at that point tanks are
able to get through a variety of
terrains but tank support Vehicles can
have a difficult time traveling through
mud snow and other rough terrains if
conditions degrade you know bridges are
out excessive mud deep snow that can all
disrupt the the supply chain and make it
a lot harder to properly refuel and
rearm those tanks and for the tanks to
operate the most effectively Ukrainian
forces will need to manage a pipeline of
high quality fuels the turbine engine in
the Abrams is a multi-fuel engine the
efficiency and the effectiveness of the
you know of the engine would be reduced
if you're using kind of a lower grade
fuel the kind of diesel fuel that the
military uses will work quite well in
the Abrams and as long as the ukrainians
have access to uh to Quality diesel fuel
they should be able to operate the the
Abrams just fine but the US's Abrams
tanks aren't the only tanks that Ukraine
needs to plan for it will need to manage
Supply chains to support multiple types
of Tanks including its existing
soviet-era t-72s Britain's Challenger
twos Germany's leopards and the US's M1
Abrams tanks and while other tanks may
not require as much fuel as the Abrams
Grazer says Britain's Challenger 2 and
Germany's leopard are also technically
more complex than Ukraine's current
tanks there are going to be some
differences in the details as far as how
they're supported and I think that's
going to be a big challenge for the
ukrainians in having to maintain three
separate Supply chains to be able to
support these three different tanks that
are going to be receiving here over the
next couple of months so if Ukrainian
forces will need to navigate complicated
technology gas guzzling engines and
create multiple complex Supply chains
why did the U.S decide to send the
Abrams tank Ukraine needs foreign tanks
because the ones they have keep getting
blown up by the Russians so they need
more tanks and the Abrams 10 is a good
one there aren't that many old Soviet
tanks around for Ukraine to go shopping
for it was designed for the cold war to
fight the Soviet Union in Eastern Europe
so for the Abrams to go to Ukraine now
as in a way almost like it's going home
right now what Ukraine needs is
offensive capabilities not so much
defensive to protect their territory but
offensive to enable them to drive the
Russians out of their Turf if you want
to take background in a ground war you
need that kind of heavy armor to do it